[Music]
welcome back to Hannity tonight you're
hearing the very painful stories angel
families moms and dads that have lost
their loved ones to illegal immigrant
crime you know the manufactured crisis
like the Singh family they lost their 33
year old police officer son brother Ron
Ronaldson just a day after Christmas
when he was killed during a traffic stop
in Northern California
the suspect Gustavo Perez Arriaga had a
long criminal record and suspected gang
ties but California's sanctuary policy
protected him from being handed over to
ice which would have meant he would have
been deported officers saying was an
immigrant a legal immigrant who came
from Fiji came to this country as all
immigrants do legally because they want
a better life the hope the dreams for
themselves their families their kids to
raise a family but it was cut short by a
criminal alien who never should have
been here in the first place and who was
in the criminal justice system and
should have been long deported joining
us now is talk about his life is his
brother Reggie Singh is with us Reggie
thanks for being with us I know this is
still fresh this is raw for you you met
with the president yesterday you were in
Texas where we were what the president
say yes the president uh just wanted to
know how the family was doing if there's
anything he could do to help out we had
a good conversation about ro nail he
asked some questions
that was it yeah what you and your
family came here legally it takes a long
time right you've got to go through take
some time to get here yes we came here
2003 it takes about ten years I would
say to get just to go through the whole
process to do a medical background check
criminal criminal background if
everything's fine then the process is a
a procedure to the next step but yeah
it's a process and then you come here
in Ronald's case we were a green card
holders for five years then he was asked
to get it get it's a citizenship in
order to become a law enforcement and he
always wanted to be in law enforcement
that was his dream he wanted to protect
and serve he always wanted to do that
yes he always wanted to be a law
enforcement a cop in California Wow and
that's that was one of the reasons we
came here so he could become a cop
well let me deal directly with the fact
and you heard the comments of then
Governor Jerry Brown dismissing the fact
that the sanctuary states that status of
California had anything to do with this
but the reality is is the individual
that killed your brother was already in
the justice system and because because
of the sanctuary laws that prevents the
state of California from informing ice
handing over on the release date of
their prison sentence handing over to
ice that individual for deportation and
enforcement of federal law does that
make it even more bitter for you it's
hard to lose your brother but when you
find out we had him he should have been
deported and he was protected by us by a
state law so yeah we we wake up with
anger that this could have been
preventable that was I wasn't aware of
what century of state and this rules and
regulation meant but I was explaining
how it worked but I could have been
preventable we wake up with anger that
you know he should have been deported at
the first place but he wasn't due to the
century law we have in California yeah I
know this is fresh like the Corcoran's
this is new this is hard painful you're
in our thoughts and prayers I'm so sorry
it sounds like your brother everything
I've heard I've interviewed the sheriff
I interviewed the police chief out there
they loved your brother he was a great
cop they they're they're just devastated
themselves so you're in our prayers
thank you so much for being with us
tonight
and the best year family thank you thank
you so much